- We watched "South Park",
we watched "Family Guy",
it's time for "American Dad".
Let's see these medical scenes
and if they're legit or not.
A huge thank you to Dropbox
for sponsoring a portion of this video.
- The world needs anti-venom, Steve.
Think of how many lives we'll save.
- I think the number is
something out of this world,
like 100,000 people, I read somewhere,
that lose their lives to snake bites.
So anti-venom is incredibly important.
But you know anti-venom
works on the same principles
that vaccines work?
We give animals the venom,
they make antibodies,
we get that serum and
we use it as anti-venom.
- Now hold up a second, I wanna
make sure we got a good one.
- There's experts out there that,
based on the size of the
snake, the color of the snake,
the pattern of its casing, for
lack of better words, scales,
and the shape of its
head, they'll make a call
on what kind of snake it is
and what anti-venom you need.
I have no idea what this is.
I would describe it as an
orange-y, yellow-y anger snake.
- Ow, it's him and he nipped me!
- Oh my God!
- I got nipped.
Quick, grab his tail.
- Ah, ah!
- Oh.
Okay, all right, right now,
they're already breaking
the first rule of snake bite.
The first rule of snake bite,
it sounds like fight club,
is get away from the snake.
That's literally the first
thing, not pick it up
and bring it with you.
Oh, that's a lot of bites, a lot of bites.
- Ow, I got nipped a
whole bunch right now.
Ow, let's bag this sucker.
- Ah, ah!
- Get him in there.
- Why are they bagging it?
Just run away from it,
get medical help now.
If you don't get anti-venom in
the first three, four hours,
it's a problem because the
damage can already be done.
Remember, anti-venom
neutralizes the venom,
so if the venom has
already done the damage,
it's not gonna reverse that damage.
- We did it, Steve.
(Steve screaming)
- This is evil to laugh at, but
there is some misinformation
that comes about when people
talk about snake bites.
I learned about this in
a wilderness lecture.
Don't do the suck out venom trick.
It's gonna introduce more bacteria,
maybe even give you more
venom into your mouth.
Don't bleed the area, don't
raise it above your heart
'cause that's actually gonna
make it drain into your heart.
Try and stay calm and
get help immediately.
That's the number one
thing you need to do,
because it's about the anti-venom.
Is it anti-venom or anti-venom?
(record scratches)
- Anti-venom.
- How would you say it?
Write it in the comments, with syllables?
(Sam laughs)
- Dad, have you seen Jeff?
He never came home last night.
- Oh yeah, he volunteered himself
for a deadly experimental
surgery at the CIA.
- What?
Why didn't you stop him?
- I guess I don't care
whether he lives or dies.
- Experimental treatments are
so important for us as humans
and I encourage people
to sign up for trials
because there are ethics
boards that prevent them
from going too far.
But I don't know if I could
actually recommend that
as a doctor.
That sounds antithetical to my training.
- Stop this atrocity at once!
- Oh Hailey, you're here.
As Jeff's legal guardian,
you need to sign this release
before I can do the operation.
- Intelligence enhancement?
Out of curiosity,
has this worked on any
of your test animals?
- There's one goose that's now in Mensa.
(Doctor Mike laughs)
- What's the score of IQ
that you need for Mensa?
Is it 140, 150?
- Did I get it right this time, Doc?
- Oh my God, you have
your gown on backwards.
You're supposed to have
it open to the other way.
I mean, I guess it depends
on what you're trying to do.
- Hopefully here to stop me
from doing this super dangerous thing.
- He's all yours, Doc.
- Oh.
- Oh no, what are they doing?
Cranial surgery of some kind?
Are they uploading the
Internet into his brain?
As a doctor, I will tell
you, that is not feasible.
Although, with how much time
you've been spending on TikTok,
I will say you're getting close.
- Did it work?
- Let's find out.
Which of the little people
is wearing his hospital gown correctly?
- The left one.
- This one...
(everyone sighs)
Seems to have had a bit
of a sartorial snafu.
- I just realized, on
the back of the thing,
his diploma says Hardvard.
(Doctor Mike laughs)
Back to the show in just a second,
but first, I wanna thank
Dropbox for sponsoring
this part of the video.
If you've watched my channel before,
then you know I don't
do this all by myself.
I may sit in front of the
camera and say the words,
but so much of the
production and editing work
is done by the rest of my team,
and while Dan might be
sitting behind the camera,
we've actually got team
members all around the world,
so it was important to me
to find an efficient way to communicate
with my international staff.
That's why I've been so
happy with Dropbox Capture,
which allows me to get
my message to my team
across screenshots, gifs
or simple videos recorded
right on my screen.
Here's how it works.
I've recently been developing new merch
with my designer, Caroline.
What I used to do is receive
an image of her design
and then write her a lengthy email,
detailing what changes
I wanted her to make.
With Dropbox Capture,
I don't need to write
this long and confusing message,
because I can quickly record myself
and my screen simultaneously,
mark it up with areas that
I specifically want changed
and then send it over for
her to watch on her own time.
Gone are the days of
struggling to find the time
for us to hop on a call
or having to make sense of verbose emails.
It makes it so easy for
me to say what I mean
without scheduling anything.
Get your message across
clearly and quickly
with Dropbox Capture.
Download and try it today for free
by clicking on the link in
my description box below.
Huge thanks to Dropbox
for sponsoring this part of the video.
Let's get back to the show.
- One, two, three!
- Ooh.
- Ha ha!
- Ugh.
- Francine, you raised a lightweight.
- In general, women have a
harder time processing alcohol.
A lot of times, this is due
to body size and body habitus,
but it could also be due to a lower amount
of the enzyme that breaks alcohol down,
known as alcohol dehydrogenase.
- Ultimate Kelly's!
- What's in it?
- Don't worry about it.
- That's a lot of drinks.
This is an example of binge drinking
and something you shouldn't do.
And I wonder if that's absinthe
and does it have true wormwood in it.
Wormwood does make you hallucinate,
but I think modern absinthe
doesn't have wormwood in it anymore.
- Honey, you sit this one out.
They don't call her the
Kidney Killer for nothing.
- I mean, if you drink
alcohol to this extent,
it could be a kidney killer.
Not only does it raise
your blood pressure,
which damages your kidneys,
but it also affects your heart,
which damages your circulation,
which damages the kidneys,
but it also damages the liver,
and chronic liver failure
can impact your kidneys.
So it's a one, two,
three KO on the kidney.
Oh, here we go.
The ab muscles.
♪ Take you back, do do do do do do ♪
♪ Take you back ♪
- That's so cool that her kidneys sing.
Mine never sing.
- What's the matter?
- The alcohol.
I can't take it anymore, Joe.
I'm, I'm shutting down.
- You could get acute kidney injury
from drinking too much alcohol.
Usually, acute kidney injury does resolve
if you stop drinking the alcohol
and rehydrate appropriately over time.
It's chronic kidney injuries
where you get in trouble, CKD.
- Goodbye, Joe.
I'll always remember that
trip we took to the anus.
- Your kidney do not go to your anus.
Is that a solar system joke?
- Inseam, always 20 inches.
- You're telling me
I'm not growing at all?
- Actually, that's the thing
we check on pediatric visits.
We have a growth chart that
we plot as children age
that you're really trying
to see what percentile
children are in.
Not so much how fast they grow,
but are they still staying
on that same percentile,
or at least close to it?
'Cause imagine you have a child
that's on the 50th
percentile, 50th percentile,
and all of a sudden, they drop off
and they're below the 10th percentile.
Now, all of a sudden,
you need to investigate
why that's happening.
- What can I do for you
today, little buddy?
You wanna do something about that skin?
- I'm here because it's
come to my attention
that I am not growing.
- This, by the way,
looks exactly like all
pediatricians offices.
- You wanna know the secret to growing?
Get lots of sleep, eat lots of veggies
and always remember your inner worth,
'cause that'll make you feel 10 feet tall.
- Oh, okay, I would've left
that last corny bit out,
but the rest of it sounded really good.
And the reason sleep's so important here
is because only with adequate sleep
does your hormonal system
function optimally.
We're talking about growth hormone,
testosterone for this gentleman.
- Much can be done about your height.
Are you familiar with
the abominable sciences?
- There is a doctor who I'm
seeing pop up across TikTok
and other social media selling a procedure
for limb lengthening?
And initially, this
procedure was really created
for limb straightening, for
those who had bowed legs.
Now it's being used to increase height
by basically fracturing the legs
with nails on top and bottom,
spreading them out millimeters,
and then allowing the bone to heal
and then doing that over and over again.
To me, it sounds Draconian.
I don't know, would I ever in my life,
recommend that to somebody,
because if you are struggling
with your confidence
or your mental health
and you think two inches of height added
is gonna solve that for you,
it's not the two inches of height
that's gonna solve that for you.
That's my thought process.
- One of my success stories.
- I used to be six inches tall.
Now I'm daddy's favorite.
Look at me walk.
- Oh my God.
- What is this alien?
♪ The surgeon cuts at night. ♪
- There's no soap there, champ.
♪ I'm gonna cut you, Steve ♪
♪ I'm gonna cut you right ♪
- You know, it's funny, surgeons
do listen to really loud
and usually dramatic
music when they operate.
- Steve, there's something
I have to show you.
When I was a boy, I
used to carve my height
here on the bark.
This extra deep one is from a few years
when I didn't grow at all.
It's called the Smith stall.
But eventually, I shot up six inches.
- Growth spurts happen at different ages.
For me, I went into high
school 6'3 and then never grew.
- Doctor, we shouldn't even be in here!
Let us go!
- We're thirsty too.
We want orange juice now!
- My apologies, but a hospital can't allow
their violent patients
to run about freely.
- And what does that mean?
- A better life through lobotomies.
- Oh no.
You know, Russia was one
of the first countries
to make lobotomies illegal,
and then the US ended up following suit
when it comes to psycho surgery.
But psycho surgery is
still used to this day
in some very specific,
evidence based cases,
most notably making a
severance for epilepsy
that's drug resistant
in the corpus callosum,
which is the connection between
the two sides of the brain.
Actually, the person
who created lobotomies
won the Nobel Prize for it,
and then a lot of people have requested
that the Nobel Organization retrieve it
because they think it's too controversial.
Tens of thousands of these were performed
with (peewoop) evidence.
- Ew, look at Steve Smith.
- Is it supposed to be curved like that?
- It can be.
- Get that thing straightened out.
(boys screaming)
- What are they talking about?
It's not curved, is it, fellas?
- All right, first, I'm not looking down.
And second, they're
talking about your spine.
You've got scoliosis.
- Were they talking about his spine?
And you can't really tell
scoliosis from that far away,
so I don't buy that. I mean,
you can if you can tell
that one shoulder's higher than the other,
one of the hips is higher than the other,
or maybe if even one of the rib angles
is higher than one of the other.
But then, you can usually see that
only when a person bends over.
- Pretty as a picture, scoliosis.
- What do we do, amputate?
- Actually, all he
needs is a back support.
- It really depends on something
known as the Cobb angle,
which is, after we order
a certain type of X-rays,
we can calculate this Cobb angle
and we see how bad the scoliosis is,
and most of them really are just treated
with conservative management,
like physical therapy.
In some cases, we do bracing.
In really advanced cases,
maybe surgery is an option,
but that's only when the curve is so bad
that it's compromising
your ability to breathe
or your heart to beat properly.
- Is it like one of those belts
weightlifters wear at the Olympics
so they don't blow out their rectums?
- What, that's not why
weightlifters wear those.
That looks terrible and
that's not what they wear.
- I call her the chick
magnet, ironically, of course.
No girl wants any of that.
- I'll tell you why that device sucks,
because you cannot take a deep breath.
So what it essentially is gonna do
is gonna cause you to
splint your breathing,
which means you're not
gonna take a deep breath,
which means that the
lower parts of your lungs,
the bases that really take
a lot of effort to fill,
won't fill, and therefore, you will have,
essentially, a loss of the
lower part of your lung,
known as atelectasis.
- Dad, I know it's only what's
on the inside that matters,
but I'm just not as
strong as (Steve gasps).
- Ooh!
- You're bald?
- Um, um, there's a kid on
the football team with cancer,
so the whole defensive line
shaved our heads in solidarity.
- What?
- Yeah, that was just nonsense. I'm bald.
- I actually shaved my
head to stand in solidarity
with kids with cancer.
Here's a picture, sorry
you had to see this.
- Guys, we have huge news.
We're gonna start trying for a baby.
- Ah!
- Steve, you're gonna be an uncle.
- I love the goldfish.
- And what will I be?
- Oh, Claus, you'll be nearby.
And dad, you're gonna be a grandpa.
- Why not make the goldfish the god fish?
- [Sam] What?
(Sam laughs)
Just keep smiling, baby.
- You don't get it?
- Just keep smiling.
Why would, no I don't.
- Everyone wants to be...
- [Sam] Like the godfather?
- Yeah, but the god fish.
- [Sam] That's a bridge too far.
- Come on!
God fish, God father.
(Sam groans)
And it's a goldfish!
There's a lot of...
(Sam groans)
- [Sam] Objection.
- I'm cooking breakfast
for my sweet daughter.
- Aww, thanks Dad.
- Oh my God, please don't tell me
he's gonna put some kind of
medication in there for her
to end the pregnancy.
No, he's not.
No!
- Fresh squeezed OJ?
- Jesus, that's evil.
- Jeff, I wanted to take you out to dinner
to celebrate your efforts
to impregnate my daughter.
And here we are at the restaurant.
- Vasectomies.
- This place looks fancy.
- A vasectomy is basically a permanent,
usually near 100% effective
form of birth control for men,
and it's called a vasectomy
because it blocks or
cuts your vas deferens,
which is the tube that carries
sperm from your testicle
to your peen.
- How big is your minestrone?
- Is this man not aware he's
here for a medical procedure?
- Can you tell me a little bit
more about your colonoscopy?
Is that spicy?
- I don't think this is
the best place to eat
for someone with your cholesterol.
- Absolutely not.
If you have high cholesterol
and you're eating foods
with high saturated fat content,
you're gonna run into troubles
'cause your cholesterol
will go even higher,
raising your 10 year risk
score of having ASCVD.
- Stan, the doctor gave
you this health journal
to monitor your fitness and eating habits.
- Hey, if it ain't broke, don't fix it.
- It's broke.
- And you heard my stool sample
results, too hard to test.
- That's not a thing.
- But you're getting older,
you need to take care of yourself.
- Even when you're younger, you
should take care of yourself
'cause it'll pay dividends
for when you get older.
- If he doesn't change his lifestyle,
something terrible could happen.
- Sadly, people are
often set in their ways
until something really rattles them,
like a near death experience.
- That's actually true,
or a loved one who really cares for them
encourages them to seek care.
- What's with all the coffee?
- After the amount of cheese
I consumed at Fuddrucker's,
it takes three pots worth
just to get my system running again.
- That's too much caffeine there.
The maximum caffeine we
say safe to have in a day
is 400 milligrams, and I will say,
there are certain drinks at Starbucks,
a Venti Blonde Roast has 460 milligrams.
And then people put
espresso shots into those,
so be careful.
You're gonna start developing
some heart arrhythmias
if you keep pumping
that caffeine like that.
These diseases,
I've literally only seen
in medical textbooks.
Check out this video, lots
of great medical commentary.
As always, stay happy and healthy.
(upbeat music)